welcome to WWDC 2015 we're going to
start with OS 10 the new name for OS 10
is OS 10 El Capitan now we've done
something totally new to El Capitan and
it's the ability to work really easily
on to windows side by side so i'm just
gonna click and hold here on the green
button and you see it's prompting me to
pick a side i'll just drop it in and you
notice i get an expose of all my other
windows let me pick the new news app
just like that will be rolling out to
everyone with a free upgrade this fall
for iOS 9 we're bringing proactivity
throughout the system so say you like to
run in the morning and when you do you'd
like to listen to music well now your
phone can learn that about you and when
you plug in your headphones can offer up
now playing automatically right on the
lockscreen the transit we provide a map
that emphasizes all of the different
transit lines buses and trains subway
stations and so forth and when you tap
on a station you can see all the lines
that run through it I'm pleased to
announce that work introducing a new
application and it's called News News is
beautiful content from the world's
greatest sources personalized for you so
iPad has always supported forms of
multitasking but for iOS 9 we're taking
it to a whole new place I'm gonna bring
in the new notes app just like that now
sometimes of course I want to stay
working in notes in Safari both at the
same time so I can just tap here on the
divider and now I'm in split view next
let's turn to Apple pay first you'll be
able to add your store credit and debit
cards and for you coffee and donut
lovers dunkin donuts will bring apple
pay to
perks to their stores beginning this
fall now we think Swift is the next big
programming language the one that we
will all be doing application and
systems programming on for 20 years to
come today we're announcing the Swift
will be open source
today we're announcing apple music the
next chapter in music it's all the way
you love music all in one place and that
place is almost in a billion hands
around the world already one app one
single app on your iPhone it is a
revolutionary music service with
recommendations just for you a worldwide
live radio station with the world's best
DJs an exciting way for fans to connect
with artists and of course this is
joined by the itunes music store the
best place to buy music you can search
your music library but now you can
search and stream the millions and
millions of songs that we have on itunes
apple music will be just 999 a month the
cost of an album